ARUN NAGARAJAN: My name
is Arun Nagarajan.
I'm with the developer
relations
team for Google Apps.
CHRISTOPH SCHWAB-GANSER:
My name is Christoph.
I'm the lead engineer of the
YouTube Analytics API.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And this session
is Ad Hoc Analysis
with Google Apps Script and
the YouTube Analytics API.
So before we get started, how
many folks here have content
on YouTube or work for someone
that has content on YouTube.
Awesome.
That's what I thought.
We're in the right room.
Last quarter, I think it was
last quarter, we announced
that YouTube has a billion
unique viewers a month.
That's billion with
a B. That's big
even by Google standards.
And it's quality apps from
content from folks like you
that really make that
number possible.
Now, as content owners, as
developers, you may feel that
the amount of volume of analysis
and analytics coming
at you is a sea of data.
That's petabytes of data
in a lot of ways.
In this session, what you're
going to learn is how could
you take that and package it,
share it, and automate it so
that you're able to get
meaning out of it.
So the whole idea is to take the
YouTube Analytics API and
using a really powerful product
called Google Apps
Script, write custom analysis,
do ad hoc analytics using the
API for the data source.
So the agenda for today is I'm
going to start off talking
about what Apps Script
is all about.
So we're just going to give you
a quick introduction to
Google Apps Script.
There's a lot to cover, so we'll
just have a high level
introduction.
Then, Christoph is going to
talk about the YouTube
Analytics product itself.
Then, he's going to cover the
API, which is really important
for developers.
And then, I'll talk about how
you will be able to marry that
API with Google Apps Script,
which is the programming
platform we're going to use
for this demonstration.
And then, just in general, be
able to do more with the
YouTube Analytics product.
All right.
Sound good?
Let's get started.
So the first thing I want to
talk about is just introduce
you to Google Apps Script.
Google Apps Script is a Cloud
based JavaScript platform that
allows you to do more
with Google.
The products you love like
Gmail, Drive, Sites, Docs,
Sheets and more have APIs built
into Google Apps Script.
So you're able to write
automation.
You're able to write
integration.
You're able to write UI, even,
that can be serviced into
these products.
And the best thing is
that it's not just
about Google Apps.
You're able to call other
Google APIs, like the
Analytics API, or even
third party APIs,
like Twitter's API.
And the great thing about all
that is that it's all just
JavaScript.
So you're able to learn
this really quickly.
You're able to get productive
in it really quickly.
So it's a lot easier
to show this than
talk about it, I think.
So what we'll attempt is a live
demo of writing a simple
script that does a couple of
integration scenarios.
So let's get started.
So I'm going to go
to my Drive.
I could either click on Create
and Script or my favorite
approach, which is
script.google.com.
Really easy to remember URL,
and what I'm going to do is
this is the welcome screen.
I'll hit Close.
And I'm just going to write some
code that hopefully will
make a lot of sense
to you guys.
So first thing first is that
you're seeing that auto
complete is really
assisting me.
So it's verb followed by noun.
I'm in my case, I'm using a test
inbox so I don't have to
worry about this timing
out on me.
But you'll want to have
thresholds available for that.
And what I can do, as well, is
just write a really simple
loop and then just iterate
through that.
It's hard coding standing up.
Let's see, I'll just
get threads.
I'll get the message subject so
you can see that it's even
auto completing within
a collection.
And for functional programming
like a language like
JavaScript, that's really
impressive.
A dynamic language
like JavaScript.
What I'll do now is take the doc
that I created, and I'll
get its body.
And auto complete really helps
me out, especially when I
forget what the function
is called.
I'll write the message,
and close it.
So I'll call this Gmail
Archiver, save it, and now
this script itself
is in my drive.
So it's a first class citizen.
You know where to find it.
It's easy to find
icon as well.
It's a little arrow, and what
I'll do now is just hit run.
So you can see that we're in a
cloud IDE, so I'll authorize
this script.
Even though I wrote it,
it's important to
give it some identity.
So it's going to run as
me, and I'll hit run.
So now, when I go into my drive,
you can see that a new
file popped in and I
can open that, and
that's my Gmail messages.
And you can see that those
are the messages I
have in my test inbox.
So the whole thing of what we
just showed here is that I
think we have about 7
or 8 lines of code.
It's really easy to write
JavaScript with Auto Complete.
All I had to do was go to a URL
in a web browser and then
hit run rather than compile,
deploy, manage, configuration,
and things like that.
So that's a Google
Apps Script.
What we just showed you is
accessing Gmail, and then
populating a document with it
dynamically that we also
created on the fly.
So that's what Google Apps
allows you to do.
So let's review some of
the properties of
what we just saw.
So you write code in a browser,
really good syntax
highlighting.
You saw line numbers, just a lot
of really nice things that
makes you feel at home.
It's not something that you have
to start up Eclipse or
something a little bit more
heavyweight to work on.
It's really easy to
find your code.
It's in Drive automatically.
You run it on Google servers.
So your code, when you hit
run, fires up in our data
centers and acts
on your behalf.
So that's really powerful, and
you don't have to worry about
configuration and deployment
of servers
and things like that.
And the best of all, it comes
with the set of integration
APIs to the apps I mentioned,
Gmail and so on.
But also, you can write your
own integration logic,
anything that has
a standard API.
So we have JDBC connectivity.
We have HTTP connectivity,
and so on.
So a bunch of Google products,
ability to surface HTML and
connect to third party APIs,
and a bunch of utilities to
make your programming lives
easier, formatting all the way
to things like locking and
cashing, which are really hard
to write from scratch.
And the best part is that it's
just JavaScript improved with
Google APIs that run on
the Google servers.
So that in a nut shell is
Google Apps Script.
And now, Christoph is going
to talk about what YouTube
Analytics is.
CHRISTOPH SCHWAB-GANSER:
Thank you.
So Arun already mentioned that
YouTube has now over a billion
monthly active users.
I mean, this is just a
staggering number.
I think this success has been
made possible through all the
YouTube channels and partners
that uploaded this content in
the first place.
We at YouTube Analytics want
to support these YouTube
creators to make smart decisions
for their content on
YouTube so that they can track
their performance, they can
understand their audience
better, and that they can know
how the content is
being consumed.
For this, we catch every view
and every like in many other
user events in YouTube, And we
attribute those to the right
videos and sum this up to
the level of YouTube
channels and partners.
We then take those reports and
surface them to the owners
through our user interface
at youtube.com/analytics.
So now, I would like to quickly
introduce you to this tool.
It's really an amazing
product.
It will also help you to get
started with the APIs.
It's going to give you more
context around the data that
you expose.
So here, I'm currently logged
into a content owner, and this
content owner is associated
to Google.
And he does not monetize
his videos.
So therefore, there are no
earnings, and that's expected.
So that's not a [INAUDIBLE].
So as you can see, we are now
on the overview page, and we
have many more detailed
reports available on
the left hand side.
And these reports with the
overview page are accessible
for all videos on all channels
and all shows
of the content owners.
And you can also get a report
for each country and different
date ranges up here.
You see on the top, there are
the performance metrics, so
the views followed by for how
many minutes his content has
been watched.
Also the earnings, and then the
engagement metrics like
the likes, the shares, and the
comments and so forth.
Further down, we have to top
channels and the top videos of
this content owner, either by
views, minutes watched, or
estimated earnings.
Further down, we have some
highlights around the
demographics of the viewers and
also where the viewers are
coming from.
What's the location
of viewers?
Also, the playback location, the
traffic source, so really
this tells you from where users
navigate to your content
on YouTube.
Then, you also have a report
about playback location.
So this is going to tell you
what were the playbacks on the
YouTube watch page or on mobile
or was it using the
embedded player.
So this means on other sites,
embedding YouTube videos.
So now, for the example.
I'm going to drill
into this report.
I want to find out what
sites embed this
content on the videos.
So in this report, we see how
the different types of
playbacks changed over time.
And we also have here a link
that brings us to all the
sites that embedded this
content owner's videos.
And now, we are on
the lowest level.
So now, we see the sites that
contributed most playbacks to
this content owner.
OK, this was just a short
example to show you the large
number of reports that we have
available at YouTube Analytics.
And now with the API, we
basically make these reports
available for you for the
developers so that you can go
and create awesome
applications.
So we really want to empower
you to provide services to
YouTube channels and
YouTube partners.
And also help partners to
integrate with our partners
and with our data to customize
their video reporting.
So many large partners probably
don't want to give
their employees access
to our UI.
Rather, they want to extract the
data that's relevant for
their employees and ship it off
using some other tools.
So the API is based on the
same data as the UI.
So therefore, the numbers will
match with every query.
Also, this is a pure
querying interface.
So you really have to specify
precise questions like, what
are the views and the likes for
a particular video over
the last 30 days?
Or, request to the API has to be
authorized using OAuth2 by
the owner of the entity that
you request a report for.
And this supports two different
types of accounts,
YouTube channel and
YouTube partners.
Now, probably now you want to
know how we can specify the
query, how we can drill
into this data set.
For this, we have three
important terms, so dimension,
metrics, and filters.
So dimension and metrics are
terms of the data cubes.
On this slide I have a small
data cube with three
dimensions, and the dimensions
are the criteria used to group
the data of the report.
So for example, of the country
where the user event was
originated, is coming from, or
the video that was associated
with the user event.
But also the time when
the event happened.
So the metrics, they are
basically in the
cells of the data cube.
And they are the measurement of
user activity, like users
watching a video or subscribing
to your channel,
or liking your video or
favoriting and so forth.
So with the filter, you
can cut out the
slides of the data cube.
So for example, if you only
want to have a report for
France, you could cut it in one
way or if you want to have
a report for video B, you
can slice out this.
In our documentation,
we refer to report.
That's the combination of
dimension, metric, and filters.
And that's really important,
because we do not support all
combinations of those
entities.
So let us look at the
live example now.
So I want to get a report
for a channel
of our content owner.
For this, I'm going to first
look at what reports are
available for content owners.
So I'm going to look at
the documentation.
So I already navigated to our
developer site, and I see that
when I don't specify any
dimensions, so I don't want to
have a break down by a
dimension, just the bare
metrics, and I want to filter to
one channel, I can use any
combination of all
of these metrics.
And now, for the example I'm
going to pick use, likes, and
estimated minutes watched.
So with this, I'm going to go
to the YouTube API Explorer.
Eh, Google API Explorer.
This is a tool which is
available for all Google APIs
of the latest generation.
It's really an awesome tool
to explore Google APIs.
You see, I navigated already to
our API and our method, the
query method, and you
immediately see the required
request per meter.
So IDs allows you to specify
what account you want to use
for the query, and the start
and the end date will allow
you to specify via the date
range that you want to be
included in the report.
And the metrics is required.
So you have to specify one
metric, otherwise, the query
makes no sense to us.
And I entered already my choice,
and also the filters.
So I filter this query to
one particular channel.
Now I need to authorize this
query by clicking this.
So now, I'm ready to
execute the query.
As you can see, by default you
get the chase and response.
If you prefer, you can
also get the CSV.
So the response contains first,
metadata around the
columns of the result table.
So what's the data type?
Is it dimension or metric?
And the name, followed by the
actual result table in the
rows element.
As we did not ask for any
dimension of the break down,
it's just going to be one row.
And it's the views--
these numbers-- the likes,
and the minutes watched.
So I now just scratched on
the surface of the API.
So if you're interested in the
YouTube Analytics API, you can
attend another session.
It's going to be tomorrow
in the same room
just after lunch break.
It's going to be hosted by
Jeremy, Dave, and Chris.
So that's it.
I'm going to hand
it back to Arun.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Thanks
Christoph.
So that was really, I think, a
really good introduction to
what the YouTube Analytics
API is all about.
There's a wealth of
information there.
When I first had experience
with it, I was really
surprised at how much data you
can actually get out of it.
And as developers, you
want to be able to
operate on it quickly.
At Google, we love data.
At Google, we love giving
you APIs to this data.
It's really important for you
guys to build tools and
applications on top
of this data.
But at the same time, there's
a whole set of choices of
programming platforms that
you can build on.
For a lot of reasons, you may
want to go to something that's
heavy weight and build something
that you want to
have full control over.
But for a lot of simple reports
and analytics, there's
a programming platform that we
think is ideal for it, which
is Google Apps Script.
Especially, when it comes to
loading information into a
spreadsheet or just building
some nice reports that you
want to give access to a
business user and shield them
from having to deal with
all the different
complexities of the UI.
Or maybe, it's too sensitive
of data to give him full
access to the Analytics UI.
So you want to build something
yourself to
package that up nicely.
So what we're going to be
talking about in the rest of
the session is how are you
able to do more with the
YouTube Analytics system?
So we give you a really nice
interface to browse
around on the web.
We give you an API to get
raw data if you want to.
But what about building
the custom report?
So in this next section, we're
going to talk about how will
you build these reports.
Then, we'll talk about how
can you share that.
So what are some of the things
that we offer you so that
you're able to take the reports
that you build, and
then share that out with the
right set of people at the
right time?
And then, automate as well.
So a lot of times you may find
yourself doing an every Monday
morning check for something.
Or once a quarter, make sure
that the numbers are
representative of what you
expect them to be.
Things like that, where,
potentially, there exists a
system that you could have that
automatically run for
you, and then push you an alert
through email or some
other mechanism of an
interesting event that happens.
So they automated part
is really important.
And the last part
that we'll talk
about, as well, is integrate.
So around, how can you take
data from other systems?
Maybe it's the website analytics
product, or maybe
it's Twitter's data feed,
and blend that and get a
comprehensive view of how it
applies to your YouTube
viewership.
So we'll talk about all
these different things
that you can build.
We'll start with build.
So very first thing you want to
do is be able to load data
into a spreadsheet.
So let's start with that.
So we'll do more live
demos, and we'll see
how that all goes.
So what I have here is I already
have a spreadsheet
open, and I already have some
scripts written against it.
All the code that we've written
for this will be all
open source and shared, so no
need to scramble down to write
anything down.
So just follow along and
see what's possible.
So what I've done is the very
first thing we've done is
injected a custom menu.
Let me zoom in a little bit.
That's a little bit
better, I think.
What we've done, first, is
inject a custom menu into a
spreadsheet, into a Google
spreadsheet.
So let's start with
clicking in that.
So what that's going to do is
fire up a little UI that's
built an HTML.
We called it the ad hoc
report generator.
You can call it whatever.
But the very first thing you
need to do is authorize it,
because it's just an application
that's running on
behalf of you.
So again, it's going
to use OAuth2.
So we're going to click
on authorize app.
That's going to open up the
standard dialogue that you're
used to for granting OAuth.
I'm going to authorize against
my work account.
It's going to say, OK, it wants
to be able to view my
YouTube analytics.
Allow access.
And then, it's going to spin
in and grab the token on
behalf of us, and it says that
you can close this window now.
I'm brought back to the
spreadsheet where I left off,
and you can see that it was
smart enough to pick up the
fact that a token was saved
under my properties.
And it says, OK, now,
you're good to go.
I didn't have to hit refresh
or anything, so you've
streamlined that in this demo.
And then, what we've also done
is really simplified the
interface to the few things
that may matter for this
particular business use case.
So everything about this is
fully configurable and up to
the developer, but we've just
built something to demonstrate
what's possible.
So I've just simplified it, the
metrics and dimensions.
And you can see that we've put
English next to what the API
offers by saying viewer
percentage, watch time and
then, also just had
simple dimensions
that may make sense.
So let's start with this.
Let's hit load.
What's going to happen is
it's going to spin.
And you can see that behind the
scenes, it calls the API
and very quickly loads that
into a spreadsheet.
Now, that was really quick, and
it made a RESTful call out
to our API and then pulled
the data in.
And there you can see that's
just the raw data, but as a
business analyst or someone
that's not nontechnical, there
really familiar with
spreadsheets.
They know how to do more with
spreadsheets than sometimes
developers do.
And I've seen that a lot,
so that this raw data is
immediately valuable for
someone that wants to
understand, OK, for ages between
55 and 64, give me the
gender breakdown.
That's important stuff that
we're pulling down here.
So let's go.
Let's keep going.
Let's see what else
as possible.
The next thing that I'll pull
down is I'll go down to just a
10 day window to keep the
data set reasonable.
And I'll say, I want to look
at watch time, minutes
watched, across the last
set of 10 days there.
So I'm going to say, load.
And again, this is
going to spin.
And behind the scenes, it's
going to pull down the set of
data that I care for.
So again, it's now
in a spreadsheet.
I can start doing some really
interesting things like click
on Data, sort range, and
say, sort by day.
And the data sorts.
These are Little things that
sometimes are really important
to be able to customize and
find the right slice of
information that's
useful to you.
What else can we do?
So we can pick a column.
We can say format it to have
conditional formatting of
value greater than 100,
make the text green.
So you're able to pull out any
intelligence there that is
immediately, visually
available.
You can also take advantage of
other trending information
using a feature that
we released.
I think it was last year.
It's just Sparkline instead
of a range of cells.
So now, that's the Sparkline
for minutes watched for the
last 10 days of April.
And I can drag that across and
then see that for view
duration and view percentage
as well.
And this is just the
April and report.
So now, you've taken numbers
away and just built a very
simple report that can be
immediately looked at and
shared and printed and all sorts
of things that might be
important for your audience.
Let's keep going.
The other thing that we can
do, as well, is engagement
metrics with social media.
So I'll just go and say, I want
to look at where are--
oh, actually, I'm
skipping one.
Let's look at the views
and likes by country.
This is actually a fun one.
This is going to load, I think,
quite a bit of data.
I think it was close to 100
last time I looked.
So this is what countries and
are my videos being watched
in, and what is the shares?
So it was the views and likes
in those countries.
And I think when you saw
Christophe pull that up in the
channel that he had, Latin
America and the US were big.
So let's see if that's true.
So this is a lot of data.
What I can do very easily is
just select those three
columns, click on this little
icon here that says insert
chart, go to charts, pick a map,
select that, and insert.
And that's going to immediately
pull up some
geographical information
that is exactly
the data that I want.
And that correlates with what we
saw where Brazil and the US
and Mexico were more lit up
than, and also Russia, than
the rest of the world.
So these are some of the things
that you can do once
your data is in a spreadsheet.
And you can see the ease with
which someone can operate in
an interface that they're
already familiar with.
And this is what makes it ad
hoc is that you're not
precanning these reports for
your business users or your
executives.
You're giving them raw data
in a tool where they can
do more with it.
So that's the message
behind this.
And we'll take a look at one
other thing to bring this
home, which is, like
I said, we want to
look at sharing services.
And again, this is
going to whoa--
I'm showing the error
messages too.
I picked the metrics
and dimension pair.
That doesn't make sense.
But that's how you know
it's real demos.
Shares with sharing service,
there you go.
That should load.
And that loaded in behind the
scenes for us here, and so
that tells me, OK, so there's
some regional players and
there's also the big names
where are things being
reshared from my channel.
The channel, by the way, that
we're doing this analytics for
is this particular channel,
"Build your Brand on YouTube."
And there's really a lot of
good content there that I
think is interesting to look
at as well just from a
standpoint of, what are
we looking at here?
Great.
So we talked about how do
we load this data in?
So a lot of really cool stuff.
We talked about how can we build
some of this into nice
charts, like we show here?
But what if you want
to share this out?
What if you want make
this available?
The spreadsheets have a really
nice sharing model.
There's a Share button there
that's very prominent, easier
to send it to someone just
as view only access.
But it actually has some really
nice things that go
beyond that.
So here's a little
dashboard-like thing that I
built using some of the data
that I already showed, social
media and minutes watched.
And what I can do very easily
is go to file and publish.
And you can pick which
sheet you want to
publish to the web.
So this is great for, excuse
me, when you want to make
something available as
a simple to use URL.
So once this is published, what
you can do is house that
data in a Google site.
So this is a read-only copy of
the analytics that we were
able to build very quickly.
And this is filtered.
This is labeled with the
right terminology.
It's just this slice of data
that matters for your users,
and the terminology that
makes sense to them.
And they can refresher it
when the data changes.
This will reflect it, and it's
not a matter of stale data
that's on a printed
page somewhere.
The nice thing is that a lot of
formatting and the charts
are dynamic, as well, so they
can hover over things and see
what I'm looking at.
And again, site also has its
own sharing model where you
can restrict it for the down to
your domain or really any
sort of set of users you want.
So that's really nice to be able
to take the data you're
able to build into a
spreadsheet, build a nice
dashboard, and then share
it out through a URL.
But you may also want to,
sometimes, be more proactive
and push alerts to a user.
So maybe they are not very good
at going to a site every
day and checking something.
Or maybe, they prefer to
get an email first
thing in the morning.
And the great thing about Google
App Script is that it
allows you to do things.
Just like how we were able to
read email through the Gmail
API, you can actually
send emails as well.
So let's take a look at
what that feels like.
So what I have here is the
code that was powering
everything.
And like I said, all of
this will be released.
And there's a function here
called Send Nightly Email.
And what I could just hit, and
I'm just going to run it for
now, so I want to
run that email.
And what that's going to do is
here's my Gmail, and there's
the email that showed up.
My daily YouTube
sharing report.
And you can call it whatever you
want, and you can attach
it with nice HTML with inline
images and all sorts of really
fancy stuff.
All of this is really well
documented, but in this
example I just attached a simple
P&G to my spreadsheet.
So there's a lot of really
cool things you can do.
And you're able to send rich
HTML messages as well.
So something that changes the
model of someone going to a
URL to get there analytics, to
someone being able to just get
it by checking their email,
which is, again, a very
familiar interface.
One other thing you could do
is schedule things to run.
So we have this concept of
triggers that allows you to,
if you guys are familiar with
the concept of Cron, it allows
you to schedule scripts to be
run at a specified time frame.
So what you could do is pick a
function like alert on view
increase and then, say, run
it every day at midnight.
And what that allows you to do
is apply some business logic
like compare views from
yesterday to today, and if the
amount increases or decreases by
50%, send out emails to the
top people.
Let them know that,
hey, they should
figure out what happened.
Why is their video gaining or
decreasing in popularity.
Or other things.
You can look at share metrics
or your monetization data.
Things like that.
So to bring it all together,
what we're able to do here is
run your business logic on
Google data centers against
the YouTube Analytics API.
And through email, notify people
in your organization
when something of interest
happens.
And this is all possible with
just very little code that I
think you'd be surprised by
how productive you can be.
So that's the concept of
triggers, and you can really
have several triggers.
And the time frames that you
can pick are quite good.
So you could say something like,
run it on the first of
the month, and all sorts
of good stuff.
So let's go back here.
We talked about sharing.
We talked about being
able to automate.
So turning it'll push based
model, the functions
themselves can be scheduled.
And we give you storage
mechanism so where you can
drop in these details about,
what was yesterday's numbers?
And then, you can just
write some simple
code to compare it.
And you can even create things
like calendar events.
So you could have a meeting
automatically created when
something happens and YouTube
Analytics API calls a meeting
through an automated script.
So really, the possibilities
are pretty endless.
In fact, there's also the Cloud
Print API that we've
seen people write interesting
things where it automatically
sends a print job.
So the printer is ready.
There's faxing APIs available.
All sorts of stuff.
It's really fun to play around,
and I think you guys
will really agree that it's a
great way to write apps for
the Analytics API.
The last thing that I think is
interesting is when you want
to look at other
trending items.
One piece of data about
zeitgeist is
Twitter trending topics.
So you could ask Twitter, given
a region ID, what is the
trending topic at that
point in time?
And you can build all so of
really interesting things.
So one of things that you
probably noticed is that I
have a function here called
Twitter trending.
So here's what has been trending
in, I just picked
four different countries.
And what I could do now is just
say, all right, load the
trending topic.
It's going to call the API.
It's going to comma delimit the
trending topics, and then
just log it.
So the limit on this is, I
think, 15 every 15 minutes.
15 calls every 15 minutes.
So depending on how you want to
structure it, you can start
loading this in and correlate
this with the other country
information that we're
giving you.
Where did that go?
There it is.
So you're able to build these
correlation things, because we
give you the API access
to our data.
But then, also, we allow you to
call any REST based service
or SOPA service to get
data from there.
And it's up to you to be
able to blend that in.
I can't imagine I/O 13 is not
trending in the United States.
Well, no.
What the heck?
I can't explain that.
But let's take a quick
look at the code.
The code is actually really
straightforward.
There's this concept of the
trending API, and I just, like
I said, loaded in a
few region IDs.
And I'm just iterating through
that, and just parsing it
through a very simple call
and appending it to my
spreadsheet.
It's really straightforward.
And you can write some
of your own logic to
blend the data in.
Again, you can complete the
loop by pulling in the
notification part as well
saying, hey, this topic is
trending on Twitter.
Perhaps we should feature this
video on our home screen.
So there are lot of different
use cases that, if you really
think about, now become
possible.
So we talked about being
able to integrate.
So let's bring it
all together.
What are we talking
about here?
So we talked about being able
to build these reports, pull
data into your spreadsheet.
We talked about being able to
take that data that you build
very easily then share it
through email, share it
through Google Sites
and just using the
spreadsheet sharing features.
We talked about being
able to automate it.
So I just ran the function
manually but then showed you
that there's a way to trigger
your JavaScript functions to
run across various things.
And then, also integrate.
So you're able to bring in data
from Twitter or bring in
data from stock market, weather,
all sorts of really
interesting things.
And then, look at how that helps
you or hurts you with
your content that you have.
So there are a lot of technical
details that,
unfortunately, we didn't
have a time to go into.
The first one is, I just showed
you the code really
quickly, is the ability to make
outbound URL fetch calls.
That's basically an HTTP call.
A lot of really good
documentation on our site,
developers.googl
e.com/apps-script.
The search is great as well,
and you can find
what you need there.
OAuth2.
It's actually a lot simpler
than you think, a lot of
times, to implement OAuth2.
And there's a much more detailed
video we have where
we walk you through
the process.
It involves creating
a developer console
project on our site.
And it does require you to
deploy your Apps Script as a
web app so that you can
get the call back
to store the token.
Triggers allow you to
schedule things,
so it's really powerful.
All the APIs that are available
in your regular
mechanisms are available
in the triggers.
And the last thing is you have
to be aware of the quotas.
You can start using everything
that we showed you today for
free with a Gmail address.
You don't even need anything
more than that.
But if you have Google Apps
for Business, you have a
higher quota.
And in general, is
not something you
have to worry about.
But let's say you're planning
on sending out thousands of
emails or creating hundreds of
spreadsheets every hour.
These are things that you'll
want to keep in mind so you
don't exceed the quota, and you
design your apps according
to what's possible.
That's the URL where you'll
be able to find the code.
A lot of really good resources
on the Apps Script site and
the YouTube site.
We're pretty active on Stack
Overflow, trying to answer any
questions you may have.
And you can find us on Google+,
and we'll be at the
office hours at the Sandbox as
well, the YouTube Sandbox
right after this.
I think we have about five
minutes for questions, but
we're super excited to
see what you guys
can build with it.
Hopefully, you saw that by
injecting menus into
spreadsheets you don't even have
to know scripting as a
user as long as you as the
developers write the script
for your users, they
can just open up a
spreadsheet and get going.
So what, hopefully, you've seen
from this is it's super
easy get started and actually
quite powerful as well.
Thank you very much.
If you have questions, I
think we have about a
couple minutes here.
Go ahead.
Could you use the mic please?
We're recording.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Can you mention
anything about
this in Google Analytics?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yes.
So all the techniques described
in this session are
entirely applicable to
Google Analytics.
AdSense has an API, so really
anything that has structured
RESTful access, especially if
it has JSON output, all this
is possible.
Hopefully, what we're showing
here comes across as a
technique that you can employ
rather than a packaged product
that's immediately applicable to
you, the things about being
able to build the report,
sharing automating, and
integrating are just techniques
that we're showing
you that is applicable to the
YouTube Analytics API and
other APIs from Google.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
In your demo, you showed
something about
grabbing other countries.
Now, in the Analytics API it
seems like it's only one
country per dimension.
Is there any way to specify
multiple countries, like a
range of countries,
as a dimension?
Or is that something
that's going to be
planned in the future?
The reason I ask is we've got
partners who want reports on
user activity for
certain regions.
So if you think of Europe, there
would be 25 different
countries in one particular
region.
That means, one API call per
country, per YouTube video ID.
So it eats into the quota
pretty quickly.
CHRISTOPH SCHWAB-GANSER: We
don't support this right now,
but we can look into
enabling this.
We do this for our UI,
dynamically, so just roll it
up to the, summing up the
countries, which belong to
Europe or North America.
But it's not available yet.
So but you can file a
request, of course.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if you
guys are going to enable
pricing for the Analytics
API at any point
that's in the plans?
CHRISTOPH SCHWAB-GANSER: We
don't have any immediate plans
right now for pricing.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I'm just wondering because of
the quota usage and stuff like
that for large CMS.
CHRISTOPH SCHWAB-GANSER: I mean,
you can file a request
to bump up your quota, and
then we will review this.
We can talk to Jeff.
Yeah.
OK.
We were working on another
project, which is more geared
towards partners, which will
allow you to make a query
across all your videos.
So right now you can only get
the top 10 videos, the same
just as I showed in the UI, but
we are working on enabling
offline queries.
So you submit a query.
We're going to process it.
Later, you can download it, and
this will enable you to
get basically the stats
for all your
videos in one go basically.
Yeah, probably queue three,
but it's not fixed.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Cool.
Any other questions?
Awesome.
Thank you very much.
So feel free to ask
us questions.
We'll be at the YouTube
sandbox.
Please fill out the surveys.
We'd love to know what you
thought of this and hope this
was really useful.
Thank you.